[Music]
it's been over 60 years since the first
black superhero appeared in comics
but even now in 2020 the importance of
black representation
and black superheroes is as important as
ever
it was just two years ago in 2018 that
black panther broke box office records
with nearly 1.3 billion dollars
worldwide and was the first superhero
film to be nominated for best picture by
the academy
the film broke barriers for being the
highest grossing film from a black
director brian coogler
and solidified black panther is one of
the strongest heroes in the marvel
universe
turning him into a household name black
stories have always been a tell the
times
whether it's blue marvel having to wear
a full face helmet just to disguise the
fact that america's hero is a black man
or black panther dealing with
colonization as t'challa king of wakanda
these stories although fantasy at the
core continue to shed light on the dark
spots of america
since their inception in 1934 and in
1939 respectively
dc and marvel have strived to take
people out of their normal lives
and entertain them with superheroism
comedic relief
and inclusion with all that said though
it was still almost 30 years until we
would see a black superhero join the
fold
to be more specific the fantastic four
issue 52
in july of 1966 introduced the world to
black panther and was the first time
we'd see a black superhero in the
mainstream
the black panther creators dealt with
public criticism due to people thinking
t'challa's superhero persona was aligned
with the black panther party
a political activist organization
founded in oakland to combat police
brutality and other issues faced by the
black community
but the black panther party was founded
in october of 1966
three months after t'challa first
appeared black panther originated in a
time both far away
and eerily familiar in 1966 t'challa
would have witnessed the civil rights
movement the vietnam war and the rise of
martin luther king jr
and in 2018 chadwick boseman's live
iteration of black panther would have
lived through the hope of barack obama's
presidency
and america divided under donald trump's
administration and the rise of the black
lives matter movement
but black panther was just the beginning
following his success
and in 1969 marvel introduced the first
african-american superhero
sam wilson also known as falcon
starting in captain america issue 117
falcon is seen fighting along captain
america
and the rest of the avengers now
moviegoers and comic book fans will know
this
but spoiler alert to whoever's been
sleeping under a rock sam wilson would
later take on the mantle of captain
america
and on the cover of all new captain
america issue number one
in november of 2014 sam was in the scene
with the iconic vibranium shield in hand
in the years to come marvel and dc would
answer the public demand for more
representation
by creating many of the black
superheroes we know today
luke cage and jon stewart's green
lantern coming in 1971
and black lightning in 1977. tasking
luke cage would protect in harlem
against the likes of black maria
cottonmouth and my personal favorite
bushmaster
and megan jefferson pierce aka black
lightning the teacher by day
and retired vigilante by night
protecting the kids in his community
showcase and humanize not only the black
superheroes but the neighborhoods they
call home
these characters were instrumental part
in making sure real stories were told
and represented
because all too often hollywood chooses
to portray the stereotypical black guy
or black friend on screen for marvel and
dc to be that progressive in the 1960s
and 70s
was very rare and courageous now i've
been talking a lot about the first black
men to join the superhero fold
it's time for me to put some respect on
the black women
although it didn't take centuries for us
to see the female representation like it
did for the women's right to vote
the first black female superhero would
come multiple years after their male
counterparts
while 1971's the butterfly may have been
the first the era of black female
superheroes goes as far back as 1967
when ertha kitt played the role as
catwoman in the batman tv show
though catwoman was originally created
as a white woman in 1940
representation leads to inspiration and
kid's portrayal
did just that in 1973 dc created nubia
a twin of wonder woman made out of clay
often referred to as black wonder woman
she would forever be wonder woman's
shadow and never evolved out of the past
old worn stereotypes personally i would
love to see what a black woman could do
with this character in today's hollywood
landscape
created in 1975 missy knight first
appeared with luke cage and marvel
premiere
issue number 21 at the time knight's
character was more of a sidekick
but she was a rising star who eventually
became a lieutenant of the nypd
and after the loss of her right arm it
was tony stark yes
iron man himself who would actually be
the one to give her the iconic bionic
arm
she's known for launching that same year
but vastly different in origin stories
a royal monroe better known to the world
as storm has ties back to kenya as well
as america
and her adventures with x-men
encompasses both storm will go down is
not only the first black team lead in
the marvel series
but the first black female lead as well
and with her abilities to control the
elements as well as fly
storm is seen as one of the strongest
mutants on earth one of my favorite
storm storylines is in black panther vol
4 issue 18 a story that centers around
monroe's wedding with the king of
wakanda
black panther and this is a part of the
video where i gave you guys the homework
beyond the few that i've highlighted
here there are so many more superheroes
stories and adventures out there
this is just the beginning and i'm
merely touching the surface
as a comic book fan you love to see it i
learned about a black superhero who was
forced to wear a mask like blue marvel
and now we got riri williams out here
being our next iron man
in 2018 not only did we disprove the
notion that black stories don't do well
in hollywood
we proved that they could be a worldwide
success and now with the news of
chadwick boseman's passing
we only hope he knew the impact that he
had on so many
the young black and talented chadwick
bozeman accomplished what the original
black panther did all those years ago
this one opened the doors for more
opportunities to tell black stories
by black creators with black actors for
black audience to see themselves
represented
on a global stage rest easy king
wakanda forever
[Music]